state cercando anche voi un gioco che
sia fantastico istruttivo realistico e
con una grafica mozzafiato perfetto
ragazzi questo il gioco non fa per voi
bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj e
dolcissimo su empire per empire obe al
2000 che operation hibernation è che un
videogame che credo sia uno dei più
fantastici che andrò a giocare in tutta
la mia vita
mangia pesce e frutti di bosco per
diventare ciccione l'inverno arriva in
cinque minuti perfetto click dai ragazzi
state per assistere una cosa fantastica
ve lo dico sì siamo ragazzi allora che
questo è l'orologio che indica era
l'orologio che indicava l'inverno ma
oggi zio fuori jv segnerà guidare come
si deve ragazzi preparatevi perché sarà
una cosa fantastica della prima lezione
ingranare la marcia allora la marcia ma
messo avanti che questa è quella davanti
o dietro a me non importa
dopodichè si schiaccia il pedale e si fa
avanti e non ostano nemica
era l'altra marcerà l'altra fermi fermi
no
cazzo perfetto che ha bocciato dietro
come non detto allora la prima cosa che
dovete fare ingranare la marcia con la
per andare avanti perfetto la seconda
cosa è assicurarvi che non ci sia la
nostra famelico in macchina e la terza e
premere il pedale e dopo di che i
ragazzi farebbe un viaggio che non
dimenticherete mai ve lo assicuro è
perché c'è un pesce sul cruscotto toglie
che toglie i vermi ragazzi sto perfetto
c'era un pesce sul cruscotto non
chiedetemi perché [ __ ] ancora perché se
un pezzo che due pesci 2 via dai
[ __ ] ragazzi perché c'è un app che
mi gira in macchina maledizione fermi
che non vedo allora ragazzi ma che cazzo
schivando stimando roba incredibilmente
sono cadute ciliegie non si sa da dove
ma non importa via fermi vincere
derapata carmine alla regale devo andare
fermi che vado avanti allora c'è una
galleria prendiamo la galleria ok ok io
sono tanto bravo sono tanto bravo
togliti al cuore sto pezzo di merda
bravo diglielo era il tomtom dice che la
galleria va presa è così basta cazzo di
app che mi sta zitto fermi fermi madonna
de voorde voi ce la farò mai
devo dove devo andare che non ho capito
le luci sono in mezzo a cosa
oddio 2 litigi la fanno così gira il
volante idiota no alla macchina ragazzi
è normale che si gira il no fermo
madonna che si vada se pensate che sia
un istruttore di guida perfetto ha
lasciato un mi piace perché secondo me
lo sono di sicuro allora ragazzi scuola
guida costa vj e vico è nato atomici che
bastardo fermo e chi ti dà
l'autorizzazione di bocciarmi la
macchina stronzo questo luca ragazzi
scusatemi ma ci stava devo beccare una
gallery allora devono cucinare se stessa
poi si toglie dai [ __ ] madonna ho
trovato dei pesci dei pesci perfetto
mangiati di già che ci sei ragazzi
ricordatevi che non si mangia in
macchina ma io lo faccio perché ci ho
fame e mamma invece che pesci non mi può
accadere la nutella che sono più
contento novero ci sono i pesci i pesci
di me togliti dai no cazzo classic
cappotta la magma poi perché sto
guidando con la mano quindi ragazzi
ricordatevi sempre che sapete dei
pezzenti per strada dovete investirli
ragazzi sta diventasse vabbè ciao co se
volete buttarmi addosso un treno all'ora
ragazzi il nostro compito è quello di
quartu e bastardo italia è già lì
all'inizio madonna a ragazzi questo sarà
un inseguimento epico tenetevi pronte
poi così lorido stronza vieni qui vieni
qui trans toga o che ti logista anche
questo il mio clacson
vediamo vediamo di fare le cose come si
deve togliti dai cara centro dai cocer
di quella [ __ ] perché non c'entri una
gallery amati caprotti
ma che cazzo dici macchina è questa
madonna quanto grazio pesa st roccia che
mi pesa la macchina agli otto ragazzi
nella macchina inquinatissima allora
vediamo di andare dritti dritti che non
è difficile devi andare dritto dritto
dritto ma [ __ ] cole olè olè dri
bravo kazmi che non ci posso credere non
ci posso addio addio
cos'è sto casino va bene facciamo finta
di nulla
allora ragazzi è la prima a destra
prendiamo la prima destra facciamo così
vai vai vai vai vai la ride oddio che
cazzo è un tapiro un tapiro ma cos'è sta
roba non si capisce e togliti dai
[ __ ]
animale famelico stronzo di merda dove
da mille roccia è morto era ancora vivo
ma che cazzo succede chiesto tizio non
schiacciare i pedali non schiacciare i
pedali non schiaccia il manubrio no in
cambio togliti il volante mio perché
cadutogli ti dà il cazzo si ok non basta
ma chi cazzo era quello che ragazzi alla
fine in modo era semplice basta chiuso
la roccia per schiacciare il pedale e va
avanti da solo magari se io giro al
manubrio invece che la macchina è meglio
ma pare che voglio provare insegnarvi a
parcheggiare anche se la vedo difficile
voglio vedere se riescono terminati ma
dove devo andare no no no donna ok
devo stare era tutto libero c'era un
cazzo di tronco indovinate che cosa ho
preso mi son dimenticato una regola
essenziale per guidare prima [ __ ]
cosa per guidare in macchina
mettete skrillex radio
[Musica]
era 700 metri in negozio di nutella
ragazzi qualcuno ha bisogno di un
passaggio in si giorni c'è non c'è io so
il servizio taxi e vi porto io in giro
tranquilli
siete in buone mani soprattutto sto
tizio che mi sta sul culo
[Musica]
vieni qui la cosa bella e sai qual è la
cosa bella tua sorella era 300 metri fa
vj incazzato no no no ragazzi
no no no no no no ragazzi ragazzi
ragazzi ragazze
oddio ma si può fare due metri senza
girarsi in macchina e possibile di
bernake cos'hai per nate pescheria
ambulante poi fa vj acquistate fece
gratis genoa in abbondanza tieniti
regalo crediamo senti e ti andrebbe un
po di schweppes sono io e te
ma ve li sto bastardo comunque ragazzi
se vi è piaciuto come al solito shadow
argomento mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook e come non li video trovate
nella descrizione serve per gli scritti
iscrivetevi ci vediamo un prossimo video
ragazzi